some of you may have noticed and quite
old so Brady wasn't in the least bit
surprised that I never heard of a drink
which is popular with young people
called a jagerbomb the idea is that you
fill a small glass so called shot glass
with this alcoholic drink Jagermeister
and then you drop it into a bigger glass
that contains an energy drink like
redbull
everything mixes and then you drink it
quickly to me both of them smell worse
than medicine and I can't understand why
anybody should want to drink it I went
to shop and bought some heaven knows
what they thought of an aged professor
buying a bottle of Jagermeister and four
cans of Red Bull I didn't ask them Brady
had an idea he wanted to turn a
jagerbomb into really something a bit
more explosive he and Neil thought about
it and they decided that they would take
a glass of Jagermeister and onto the
bottom of it would attach a lamp of an
alkali metal sodium or potassium and
drop the glass into the redbull
we began with sodium dropped it in it
was a bit of a flop
not much different from ordinary sodium
babbling a little flash and the small
pop at the end so we thought we would
upped the game and put in potassium
chemically this experiment is really an
alkaline metal plus water I don't think
that the sugar or the ethanol in the
alcohol will make any difference in fact
alkaline metals react with ethanol very
much more slowly than they do with water
so it's a sort of disguised alkali metal
water experiment now what I thought or
expected beforehand because I was told
it was going to happen and I went there
to watch was that the shot glass would
go in and then it would be blown out and
would raise up again like a rocket and
so in fact I even persuaded Neil to put
a ruler behind the experiment on the
wall of the fume cupboard this couldn't
possibly have happened because the
reaction with alkali metals and water is
a very violent and quick one whereas if
you want to project something like a
bullet from a gun you need a much slower
steady reaction where there's a buildup
of gas that pushes the thing out so the
first jagerbomb with potassium dropped
in
there was an enormous bang and the
beaker was gone so we had to do it again
and what was interesting is the second
time with potassium
it was also flow
potassium has quite a low melting point
so as soon as it warms up and a water if
it can float off it will if the
potassium is on the surface then half of
it sticking up into the air and half of
its in the water and so when a violent
reaction takes place much of the shock
wave can be dispersed in the air because
it's much easier for example to move
your hand through air than it is through
water being a glutton for punishment
Neal cleaned up the fume cupboard and we
tried a third experiment which again
went with a really quite satisfying bang
most of the beaker was broken into some
pretty small pieces the largest piece
that was left was this piece here which
corresponds to the rim of the beaker I
haven't seen such a destroyed piece of
glassware since I made the big mistake
when I was a PhD student and I turned
the wrong tap and put a high pressure of
gas into a glass bulb and it went bang
and disappeared apart from a couple of
pieces that got stuck in my hair back up
again and there we have nearly two
inches maybe of liquid fur and you can
go right up that's there's no problem
with that
yeah I'm really surprised I thought it
would be pale green and it's really
quite dark yellow